I don't know what it's like with mothers
and daughters but fathers and sons who
is a rivalry there's bound to be a kind
particularly Brooklyn now he's 60 he's
becoming his own man and stuff this so
kind of like the way you try to score
points against each other so Brooklyn
put this picture up on an Instagram and
he put on it rockin the old school Ralph
Lauren look at that he's got three
hundred seventeen thousand likes okay so
that you know cool in his Ralph Lauren
he scroll through the comments you know
oh yeah whatever blood one of the blur
blur blur get down to this one mr. David
Beckham that's my jumper I was set at
lunch actually when that that came up on
my screen that he just posted a picture
of him and it was my jumper so I had to
tell him but I do find him going in my
wall Joe even though he doesn't think
I'm that cool dad I still find him
wearing my clothes every single day this
one's really so so this is him it's a
little video he posted on Instagram and
to reboost about the number of his
followers here we go
so it's my mom's birthday today okay
I just reached a million followers I've
got 52
he is
literally just about to walk out the
door and I could hear him talking in his
room and I thought and then I heard him
say you know I've just about just reads
a million so you destroyed that boy to
be honest you know when we were out he
gets recognized so much and that I'm
literally you know I'm known as
Brooklyn's dad now and that's that's
that's kind of I'm the one this takes a
picture of me yeah no one's buying that
just like me I've just been constant
starwars he was just like all right I
just wanted to meet you make